ha hello everybody my name is markiplier
and this is Bob here we're playing skate
3 because it's been highly demanded and
we've been trying to are you doing I
don't know yo kids taking a nap
decide just leave me alone we've never
played before and we plugged in a bottle
so we're gonna take turns playing cuz
Bob's flight leaves in about an hour so
we wanted to record something else and
this is it so how do I jump again yes I
like push whoa oh yeah no just pressing
buttons I don't know how to play this oh
okay alright well you you is capable
shut up oh that's right you have the
force that was the first goddamn ish
yeah how do I get back on it never
figured that out okay okay oh my god
jump over the side god damn it Oh Cory
Cory sound good
oh I um I don't need this anymore
Oh
haha hey a job [ __ ] your skateboard
I need a skateboard for this [ __ ] there
we go [ __ ]
God can you run to the top of this ramp
I don't know yeah that's how you've got
a console game you need at least five
fingers what screaming fast that's a
good rule looking fuller blistering
speed perfect speed speed speed MP Oh
save it come back here
feed right damn it that's a speed man oh
good that's a big did not much big kind
of slow down
yeah no no oh yeah I got it
Oh God
save me skateboard oh shut up
speed speed speed yes I got it hang on
yeah
I want the viewers out there to
experience